On tient souvent l'Europe pour responsable
des maux de notre société :
crise économique,
frontières passoires,
bureaucratie déconnectée.
Au Mouvement Démocrate,
ce n'est pas notre vision des choses.
l'Union européenne, c'est avant tout
des femmes et des hommes
défendant haut et fort
les valeurs de démocratie,
de justice et d'égalité.
C'est l'Europe des Droits de l'Homme,
bâtie après la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
qui a instauré une paix durable
sur notre continent.
C'est l'Europe de l'innovation
et de la monnaie unique
qui facilite les échanges
et qui rassemble les peuples.
Ariane, Airbus
ou encore la future constellation
de satellites Iris
sont autant de projets
qui font rayonner notre savoir-faire.
C'est l'Europe sociale
qui a permis le développement harmonieux
de tous les pays,
qui instaure désormais un salaire minimum
sur tout notre continent
et imposera dès 2024
une taxation de 15% minimum
sur les bénéfices des multinationales.
C'est l'Europe de la culture
et de l'éducation
qui permet désormais à tous nos jeunes
d'étudier et de travailler
grâce au programme Erasmus+.
C'est l'Europe de la justice
qui agit pour la protection
de nos données personnelles
pour que nos fiches de paie,
nos photos de famille,
nos agendas
ne soient pas stockés
hors de l'Union par des multinationales
américaines ou chinoises.
C'est l'Europe de l'écologie
qui soutient une transition
responsable de notre industrie
et de nos moyens de transport
en réduisant nos émissions
pour atteindre
la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050.
C'est l'Europe de l'agriculture,
première puissance mondiale,
portée par la Politique Agricole Commune,
qui agit pour protéger nos paysans
face à la concurrence déloyale
des autres continents
et les accompagner vers un modèle
plus respectueux de l'environnement.
Mais le projet européen doit se renforcer
pour faire face aux temps de crises.
Face au retour des populismes
et de la guerre,
portons des politiques communes,
bâtissons de grands projets,
Allons plus loin sur la souveraineté,
sur la défense,
sur la démocratie européenne.
Alors que le monde se divise
et devient de plus en plus instable,
défendons la dignité humaine,
l'égalité des peuples,
la liberté de pensées,
de religions,
d'expressions.
Parce que l'Europe a été bâtie
sur la promesse de paix,
agissons en Européens
pour défendre ces idéaux.
Nos idéaux.